Senate Democrats reject a bill that
would protect children born alive from
botched abortions it's no longer just
Virginia Governor Ralph Northam the
national Democrat Party now supports
killing babies after they've been born
we will analyze child sacrifice through
the ages then the pharisaical left tries
to slut-shame tucker carlson and the
most important role of the entire trump
administration coming to you it just
occurred to me yesterday and we have got
to do it
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today the the top
story the born alive abortion survivors
Protection Act totally exposes the
National Democrat Party they can't say
it's just and equal know they can say
it's just Ralph Northam they can't say
Republicans or scare mongering on
abortion national Democrats have voted
to kill babies after they've been born
we'll get to that one second but first
let's make a little money honey with pro
talis there are days there are days when
I get home I just want to take off my
shoes because my feet hurt from a very
busy day you know it's very difficult
I've got to walk up and down I got to go
grab my cigar I've got to go have a nice
glass of scotch outside a very busy
workday keeps me on my feet when I
travel I always end up walking around a
lot more than I do when I'm home and
this can make my feet even my whole body
ache maybe you've noticed that too many
people are unaware that knee hip back
and even upper body muscle tightness and
other issues can stem from improper
alignment and that all begins at the
foot specifically right at the ankle and
this is true for more than 80% of people
Pro talus insoles bridge the gap between
custom orthotics and over-the-counter
cushioned inserts they will instantly
start making you feel better they are
fabulous with over 1 million happy
customers and a 97% success rate
crotalus insoles create a better
connection between your ankle and the
rest of your body I was very skeptical
I'd really did not believe that some
little adjustment like pro tellest
insoles would make my whole body feel
better it does they're just fabulous
this week only my listeners can save 30
bucks on every pair of Pro Telus insoles
at PR o tal us.com
enter podcast 30 at checkout that's the
number 31 of the lowest prices that
you're exclusively for our loyal
listeners plus shipping is free and if
you buy two or more pairs they'll
upgrade you to free expedited shipping
give pro talus insoles to try and
experience a difference more comfort
more energy more life 90 day money-back
hassle-free guarantee you got nothing to
lose except the pain PR OT al us dot-com
promo code podcast 30 save 30 bucks on
every pair of pro talus insoles
Democrats just today shot down the born
alive abortion survivors Protection Act
abortion survivors we're not talking
about some
to limit abortion to before 18 weeks or
before 20 weeks or before 24 weeks or
whatever born alive abortion survivor
Protection Act how did this all happen
Ben Sasse Republican senator use rule 14
to bypass committees and bring this bill
straight to the floor of the Senate for
a vote this is by the way what we need
more of in the Senate we need to get
Democrats on the record they are finally
exposing their radicalism they're
finally willing to go on the record and
we should call them up for as many votes
as humanly possible green New Deal
whatever so Ben Sasse brings this thing
to the floor and initially tries to pass
it by a unanimous voice vote now why
would he try to do it that way well
because it's about saving babies who
have already been born this has nothing
to do with abortion it's an attack all
at the only connection to abortion is
that it refers to babies who have
survived abortion so some doctor tries
to kill the baby in the womb the thing
is born the babies they're alive on the
table and what Ben Sasse as bill would
do is protect that baby from being
killed while it's on the table you think
you could get a unanimous voice vote on
that wouldn't you you'd be wrong
Democrat Senator patty Murray Democrat
from the seventh or eighth circle of
hell I think or Washington one of the to
shot it down she said nope no voice vote
so then SAS comes out he says quote I
urge my colleagues to picture a baby
that's already been born that's outside
the womb gasping for air that is the
only thing that today's vote is actually
about we are talking about babies that
have already been born nothing in this
bill touches abortion access Senate shut
it down Senate Democrats shut it down
there were a couple Republicans who who
wouldn't cross the aisle I think there
were three two of them missed it because
of flight delays like Tim Scott missed
it Tim Scott didn't miss it because he
wants to kill babies on the table he
just wasn't able to get there in time
Murkowski I believe voted against it I
believe Lisa Murkowski fake Republican
from Alaska actually did I guess support
killing babies who have already been
born on the
and then a few Democrats came over to
vote for it and guys like Joe Manchin
that kind of thing otherwise this was a
strict party line vote you have now the
National Democrat Party endorsing the
killing of babies after they've been
born that is not a hyperbolic statement
that is not a scare tactic that is not
exaggerating what happened we're not
just talking about abortion in the
second trimester of the third trimester
we're talking about killing a baby after
it's been born we're not just talking
about one guy in Virginia we're not just
talking about one guy in New York we
were talking about the National Democrat
Party held in the vote held in the
greatest deliberative body in the world
or should be the greatest deliberative
body in the world and the Senate
Democrats shut it down what is it to be
born alive to survive an abortion I
think one of the excuses that they'll
use is they'll say well this doesn't
happen a lot oh how many babies you look
we're really good at abortion when we
want to kill a baby in the womb we can
kill a baby in the womb well no actually
it happens quite a lot there were many
cases of babies surviving abortion
actually there are some people who now
you know they're now adults and they've
survived abortion they go on and give
amazing testimony but this is why Kermit
Gosnell the most prolific serial killer
in American history the reason he's
rotting away in prison right now is
because he botched some abortions the
babies were born alive he would play
with the little babies and then he would
kill them he would put them in jars or
he would just kill them right off that's
that's what we were talking about we're
talking about the barbarity of Kermit
Gosnell playing with little babies and
then killing them we're talking about
the the reality of what Ralph Northam
was talking about just a few weeks ago
this does happen and Democrats voted to
let it keep happening Democrats just
voted to encourage it here's how liz
warren senator laia waffa decided to
spin it she said quote Republican
politicians just tried and failed again
to score political points at the expense
of women enough women and their doctors
should decide what's best for their
health not the Senate GOP I understand
the argument that abortion is about a
woman's health
it's not really I mean it's out it's
about the baby primarily it's about
killing a baby or letting the baby live
but I understand the argument you could
say well yeah the baby is inside a
woman's body and so she can make this
disingenuous argument that it's about
her health whether or not you can kill
that there is no argument that the baby
that has already been born that is
sitting on the table that the ability to
kill that has something to do with the
mother's health there is no there is no
argument that is a total nonsense that's
like saying bah bah bah bah bah doesn't
mean anything and what liz liz warren is
not a stupid woman she knows that and
she is just so radical that she thinks
that it is perfectly within a woman's
right to kill a baby if she doesn't like
him I don't know man I should kill a
five-year-old if she doesn't like him
that's the kind of radicalism we're
talking about and she is also so
confident that her voters are stupid
that she can conflate the two they're
totally different with this brought to
mind because I think some conservatives
are really shocked by this I'm not
shocked by this not shocked at all we've
known that Democrats support killing
babies forever for my whole lifetime at
leat I mean since 1973 we've known that
for sure so why would you be shocked
what they're shocked about is I think
conservatives thought Democrats were
just a little confused and maybe some
are some are confused about what
abortion is some are not confused and
and furthermore they're shocked that
anybody seeing the reality of it seeing
that it's not inside the womb it's not
as it's it is outside a totally separate
entity umbilical cord snipped on the
table that anybody could support killing
that baby and I'm not shocked by that at
all because child sacrifice is
commonplace throughout human history
child sacrifice is a perfectly natural
temptation all of history attests to
this every civilization everywhere in
the world all right I guess every
pre-civil ization many many societies
all throughout the world have practiced
child sacrifice it's existed everywhere
at some point this is not some
raishin this is the norm actually not
killing babies is a unique advancement
of civilization or it was now we do it
again but it was that when when we had a
really civilized society that was one of
the great advancements was we don't kill
babies here in the Americas the Aztecs
the Incas the Mayas they all practice
child sacrifice archeologists digging up
the Aztec civilization found have
already just sort of randomly digging in
the dirt found 42 children sacrificed by
Aztecs and obviously the number was much
much higher conquistadors and other
Spaniards in the new world Hernan Cortes
Bernard Bernard Ino de sahagún they were
described at length accounts of child
sacrifice obviously at the consecration
of Tenochtitlan the great Aztec temple
that was consecrated five years before
Columbus set sail there were 80,000
people executed in a matter of days
their children were not saved from this
children were sacrificed as well
the Incas practiced ritual whereby they
cracked children's skulls or they
strangled them or they just drugged them
and brought them up to a mountain and
let left them to freeze this was a
ritual called CAPA Kucha I don't know
I'm probably not pronouncing that
correctly but commonplace the Maya had a
ritual called hex the Maya rich will
believe that supernatural spirits this
is the one actually that most reminds me
of our civilization the Maya believed
that supernatural spirits feasted on the
souls of powerful people and so only by
a process of substitution where you take
an innocent baby and you use the
innocent baby
to substitute for your soul could you
appease these supernatural spirits
during especially during times of famine
or times of drought this was this was
used as well and I guess we'll get to it
in a second this is the one we look at
that we say Wow well how stupid how
superstitious how barbaric what they
thought though they though there were
these spirits out there and they were
gonna substitute the little babies for
their own we do the same thing we do
this that we sacrifice our babies
on the altar of idols and false gods
false gods of money fame career we
sacrifice our children such that those
things won't be taken from us such that
our spirit as we view it won't be taken
from us Bible documents or Bible rather
books of the Bible show that there was
child sacrifice throughout the Middle
East we're no better we'll get to this
in one second but first let's make a
little money honey speaking of safety
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer now you might already know about
their smart video doorbells and cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there is a package delivery or a
surprise visitor you will get an alert
you will be able to see hear and speak
to them all from your phone thanks to
the HD video and two-way audio features
on ring devices I love ring ring makes
me personally feel safer whether you're
in the living room in the bedroom at
work on a beach in Boca you can talk to
people you can see people who are coming
to your doors maybe it's a guest you've
invited maybe it's a guest you haven't
invited maybe it's someone dropping off
a package maybe it's someone trying to
do harm to your family it's really great
I've given this out as a gift to friends
of mine it's just really sleek a really
really great technology as a listener
you have a special offer a ring starter
kit available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home just go to
ring comm slash Knolls ken or wles that
is a ring dot-com / Knowles the Bible
documents child sacrifice everywhere
how's that for a segue well I guess it
has to do with safety doesn't it all
throughout the Middle East the king of
Moab sacrifices his air actually in the
Bible again a unique advance of
civilization specifically our
civilization judeo-christian Leviticus
and Deuteronomy ban child sacrifice
quite explicitly you see it in the
binding of issac there is the kind of
natural child sacrifice God is
commanding Abraham to sacrifice his son
and then he stays his hand says don't
don't do it this is this is
advanced immoral advanced but the state
of nature is all child sacrifice
we know that the Carthaginians
sacrificed their children we know that
the the ancestors of the Carthaginians
the Canaanites did this we know that the
Phoenicians sacrificed their children
pagan Arabs sacrificed their children to
idols we we hear this from early Islamic
sources from the Quran we know that
child's sacrifice for witchcraft are
those specifically witchcraft practice
called muti still occurs in South Africa
it occurs today we know that Uganda
recently saw an uptick in child
sacrifice they're trying to play it down
but this is within the last 10 years and
we look around at all of that and we
said gosh we're so much better huh we
don't we don't sacrifice our babies to
these ridiculous superstitious gods we
sacrifice our babies to our careers we
sacrifice our babies to our false god of
hyper individualism we sacrifice our
babies to our false God and Idol of
total freedom of choice and freedom from
obligation it's the same exact thing and
it is it actually tells you quite a lot
about the nature of Pride and sin in the
fallenness of human nature that we could
do exactly the same thing that the Incas
and the Mayas and the Aztecs and these
pagans throughout Africa and the
pre-islamic Arabs and all in the
canaanites and the Phoenicia the we we
can practice the exact same trial
sacrifice that they did on a much much
larger scale and we can pat ourselves on
the back while we do it and we could
have superiority intellectual and moral
superiority while we do it this this is
barbaric and the Democrats have become a
barbaric party so it's no coincidence
that they're embracing it as an on a
national scale I mean barbaric very
specifically the word barbarism is it
refers to foreigners the word barbaric
refers to how the speech of foreigners
is unintelligible so it just sounds like
ba ba bra bra bra bra bra bra that's a
what a barbarian is well that's what the
Democrats have become the abuse language
so much they say things that
don't have any meaning you say we
shouldn't kill babies who have been born
in her sitting on the table and
Elizabeth Warren says we need to protect
women's health what what women said what
I mean you're certainly not protecting
the half a million babies that you're
killing who are women who are girls so
that seems to cut against women's health
but what does a baby sitting on a table
over here have to do with the health of
a woman who's over here across the room
nothing
that's your bar bar bar bar bar bar bar
it's a breakdown of communication hey
this is the denial of the left that says
there's no objective truth in order to
communicate in order to have meaningful
speech there has to be some objective
truth there has to be an objective
standard about which and through which
you are speaking in order to communicate
we have to refer to something outside of
you and me if I have something that I
want to convey and then Johnny over here
what is meant to understand what I'm
going to convey the only way he can do
that is not through just our raw
subjective emotion the only way that
that can happen is if I use symbols
which are speech to refer to something
outside both of us which is called the
truth and reality and then he can
understand those symbols as referring to
that reality which he can perceive I
don't mean to be didactic but the the
entire left has missed this central fact
of reality that the entire left is
trying to deconstruct reality itself and
so it's very important to be precise and
this is also primitivism it's not just
the barbarism it's not just the
breakdown of truth it's this primitivism
I mean all you need to do is go into a
coffee shop in Los Angeles to see the
advance of primitivism you've got people
tattooing random nonsense all over their
bodies growing their hair out many of
them haven't showered in weeks
they they wash their hair with weird
little oils they eat diets called the
Paleo diet where they don't even cook
their food they're just like cavemen
they're regressing into some pre
conscious state and this is not a
coincidence it's easy to make fun of the
filthy hipster on on Sepulveda Boulevard
or whatever but it's not just to this
random funny occurrence this comes
naturally out of leftist ideology this
comes naturally from the exalting of the
noble savage the idea the fundamental
difference and there are many
differences between the left and the
right one of which is that conservatives
tend to enjoy civilization says
civilization is a good thing the great
tradition that we've inherited is a good
thing things can all go bad pretty fast
we got to be careful when we start
knocking down the pillars of our
civilization things can go wrong real
fast as Ernest Hemingway writes and the
Sun Also Rises he's talking about the
guy who went bankrupt it's AD you go
bankrupt he says gradually then suddenly
that's how civilizations can collapse
gradually then suddenly this worship of
primitivism is bizarre
we like civilization on the right but
the left says civilization has made men
worse men used to be so good this is why
they have all these ridiculous myths
about the indigenous peoples around the
world the as though the indigenous
peoples were this a uniformly angelic
perfect it's like Avatar they're just
all living in harmony with nature
singing about the colors of the wind
no they're people it's actually a fairly
racist sentiment that they are these
angels walking through the the woods
perfectly vulnerable to the wickedness
of settlers no they're people they're
people this some are good some are bad
some are nicer than others some are a
little craftier than others they have
self-interest they practice child
sacrifice some of them some do not there
they're people just like all of us but
that leftist idolatry of the primitive
leads them back to a savagery the noble
savage there's nothing noble about
savagery savagery is savagery it is
savage and and killing babies after
they've been born is savage when we talk
as conservatives about the tradition we
you know we seem to be pulling our hair
out we say you're knocking down the
greatest economic system that's ever
been built you're not
the greatest health care system that's
ever been built you're knocking down the
greatest system of law that wit has ever
been constructed you're not stop it
you're ripping apart the greatest
Constitution of any Republic in history
no no no to the reason that we're so
frustrated by this is because of how
high the stakes are we have so much to
lose the stakes are not just marginal
tax rates go up a little bit oh why the
government takes a little more of my
money it destroys wealth oh I'm gonna
have to have a smaller house or I can't
eat steak two nights a week no no the
steaks are killing babies on the table
after they've been born and having the
oldest continuously existent political
party in the world
cheering it on voting for it in the
United States Senate those are the
stakes that's what we can lose on the
bright side President Trump and the GOP
are excellent at getting the left and
the Democrats to expose themselves we'll
get to that in a second but first then
speaking of exposing themselves the left
is now trying to slut-shame Tucker
Carlson look it's something I don't
really want to think about what we have
to talk about it because it's an
instructive story first let's make a
little money honey with We the People
holsters We the People holsters are
terrific they design everything in-house
they offer custom-made holsters all
produced in the USA
they don't use any third-party mold so
it is going to fit your gun they're
constantly updating their designs
they're adding new designs every month
that lets them stay up to date on all
the newest models that come out they
have their own 3d design team measures
every micro millimeter of their guns to
ensure the perfect fit the unique and
intuitive clip design allows you to
easily adjust both the can't and ride of
your holster so that it will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
adjustable retention that's signaled
with a click sound this lets you know
your firearm is securely in place and if
you want even more tension you can just
tighten one screw and you're done custom
printed designs the thin blue line
Constitution camo American flag more
coming out each month we the people
holsters start at just 37 bucks apiece
every holster comes with a lifetime
guarantee every holster ships free if
it's not a perfect fit send it back for
a refund these are really excellent
products and you get them at a very low
price right now listeners the Michael
Noll show can go to weed
holsters comm / Knowles Kano wles enter
promo code Knowles Kano wles at checkout
get 10 bucks off their first holster
that's as low as 37 dollars and shipping
is free with an additional ten bucks off
using my promo code you're basically
making money again that as we the people
holsters comm / Knowles Kenda wles promo
code Knowles at checkout for $10 off the
up shot the good news about child
sacrifice is hard hard to find a silver
lining in that storm cloud but the but
the silver lining is the President Trump
and the GOP are very good at getting
Democrats to expose themselves this a
vote in the Senate was brilliant senator
sass did a great job getting this on the
Senate floor
we now have virtually every Democrat on
the record saying that they think that
we should be able to kill babies after
they've been born
the GOP adds in 2020 are going to be
terrific this is also by the way going
to affect the 2020 presidential race
because you've got a number of US
senators running for president Kamala
Harris Cory Spartacus Booker senator
Leah Wafaa Liz Warren any club you CH
are all of these people all of these
women are gonna have to defend this vote
during the presidential debates say do
you really think we should be able to
kill a baby after it's been born either
way they're really in a tough spot
because if they say yes then they expose
themselves as absolute barbarians and if
they say no then the follow-up question
is going to be why'd you vote for it
then the bill was very clear the born
alive abortion survivors Act was a very
clear and you voted against it and
they'll say bar bar bar bar bar bar
that's what they're gonna do they're
gonna do the same Liz Warren game well
women's health has nothing to do with
women's health bar bar bar bar bar bar
bar that's what they're gonna say and
it's going to be clear to America the
the other great little bit here it's not
just it's not just all about abortion a
president Trump last week we weren't
able to get to it in the show but I
really want to cover it now President
Trump during a cabinet meeting announces
that on the 4th of July of this year he
will host a salute to America
parade or gathering and nobody has
really understood why he did this but I
do and I really appreciate it here's
President Trump announcing we're
thinking about doing on the 4th of July
or there abouts a parade a salute to
America parade it'll be a really a
gathering as opposed to a parade I guess
you'd have to say yes perhaps at the
Lincoln Memorial we're looking at sights
but we're thinking about doing something
which would become perhaps a tradition
salute to America on July 4th or July
4th weekend somewhere around that area
and David you're taking charge of that
and you'll see how it how it works out
with schedules and everything else and I
think it could be a very exciting day
and the fireworks is there anyway so we
just saved doing the fireworks
you get free fireworks because it's
already being done look we're gonna
piggyback on the fireworks we're gonna
save a lot of money it's gonna be great
now this came after President Trump
wanted a military parade which was
supposed to happen last year they
delayed it the local DC government ran
up the costs of it became untenable
there was too much going on so now he
says we're gonna have a salute to
America parade and the left is mocking
him for it the left is upset about this
why they're saying well that we already
have 4th of July celebrations yes sort
of I mean do we have a national
celebration being run out of the White
House I don't know that we have that if
we have something called a salute to
America it's a little different than
just eating hot dogs or even
commemorating what happened in 1776 it's
a salute to America as it is our country
and the left is mocking it not because
it's redundant but because the left
doesn't like America President Trump
could have said we're gonna have apple
pie week yeah we're gonna have apple pie
and puppies week in America and the left
would hate it it's a UH Oh apple pie
yeah we're gonna have watch baseball
week oh I hate baseball I like soccer
because what they're exposing is that
they don't like the country it's a
brilliant idea I really like it I really
like it is
we're in an age of cynicism of performed
apathy of oh I'm too cool for America
I'm too good for that
oh I hate America certainly on the left
you see that oh I hate the middle of the
country oh I when I go abroad I tell
people I'm from the coasts mm-hmm oh I'm
so ashamed
I'm so embarrassed by America the only
the only poll that they care about
you'll notice this when you talk to the
left they're so humiliated because the
rest of the world doesn't approve of
President Trump which by the way isn't
even true I mean Bibi Netanyahu and
Israel is campaigning with pictures of
Donald Trump over there a lot of people
like Trump quite a lot but there's some
they say oh I'm so embarrassed I want
the world to like us oh they're just
like really insecure little teenage boys
and girls and this is unbridled
patriotism an ironic nothing cynical
about it I love America where is salute
America it's the maggot on a parade with
fireworks it's gonna be a great idea and
it gets Democrats on the record as
talking it down is talking down America
is talking down Americans people notice
this stuff voters notice this stuff they
might not register it with pollsters
might not be at the top of their mind
but it does register and Democrats are
going to have to pay a price if we still
have a country I have an idea a very
important idea the most important role
of the Trump administration I have a
plan for Donald Trump to become the
first woman president if you want to
hear it you've got to go to daily wire
calm if you're on Facebook or YouTube
it's ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership what do you get you
get me you get the end reply mnsure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt wall show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions backstage which we
had last night there was a lot of fun
you get another Kingdom and you get this
you get the salute to America tumbler
you're gonna want to get this before the
4th of July because every firework that
goes off you're just gonna get and it's
gonna fill up the whole tumbler and if
you don't have it you're gonna drown so
make sure you get it before the fourth
of July
get it get it even sooner folks there's
a lot of great stuff going on president
Trump is now his second summit with Kim
jong-un if anything comes out of that
the tsunami is gonna be overwhelming go
to daily where die calm we'll be right
back with a lot more
I have an idea
it occurred to me yesterday was speaking
to Liz wheeler from oann and it just
occurred to me and I the more I think
about it the more I love this idea I
think I figured out the only way to
crack up the left's ridiculous gender
ideology all these stupid pronoun
battles in the bathrooms and all that
before he leaves office for just one day
president Trump needs to identify as a
woman Donna Trump for one day there are
only two possible consequences of this
either the left will have to admit the
absurdity of gender ideology
transgenderism or the left will have to
celebrate Donald Trump as the first
woman president beat Hillary to it
beep Amy Klobuchar beat Kamala Harris
beep Liz war and beat Donna Trump that's
what we'll call him for that one day
Donna Trump will become the first woman
president if he remains married to
Melania he will be the first gay
president not just the first gay
president the first lesbian president
not just the first lesbian president the
first gay married at lesbian president
married to an immigrant it will be a
glorious moment now you say that's ok
that's a funny line that's ok whatever
but no I actually first of all if any
president we're gonna do this it would
be Donald Trump the greatest troll ever
to occupy that office but why wouldn't
he do it let's say he does it obviously
he says I'm a woman today I issue an
executive proclamation I am a woman and
I will go by Donna what is the left
gonna do they'll say no you're not yeah
well you could say how dare you how dare
you assume my gender they say yeah well
you're just you're not really a woman
that did you say that to Caitlyn Jenner
did you say that to all these
transgender athletes they're transgender
they're men who are pretending to be
women who are beating all of the women
in these competitions how dare you she
said well
okay okay let's say we grant that you're
a woman you're not the first woman
president so are you saying that
transgender women are not real women
well gosh I guess that is sort of what
I'm saying well I get and they have to
something has to give and I don't really
care which gives if because you can go
back by the way gender is fluid you can
just identify as a man the next date and
go right back to being Donald but for
just one day that's all it takes to
become the first woman president the
first lesbian president the first
lesbian gay woman president married to a
immigrant that's all it takes is one day
and if he does that for one day I don't
care how it turns out either gender
ideology falls apart because it's absurd
or Donald Trump goes down the history
books is the first woman president
it is a win-win president Trump is
really good at win wins he's really good
at wedge issues he's really good at
driving a wedge between the Socialists
of the Democrat Party and the
establishment of the Democrat Party
which doesn't want to use that word he
did it at the State of the Union he
split AOC and all those people from
Nancy Pelosi and all of those people
he's really good at driving wedge he's
really good at driving a wedge between
the pro-worker
blue-collar Democrats and the globalist
neoliberal Democrats that was basically
the story of the 2016 election and now
he could drive a wedge between the
transgender acedia logs and the
feminists the people who say gender
doesn't mean anything men can define
womanhood it's not a real thing and the
feminists who say no no no womanhood is
a real category women have been
historically put upon and we need to
focus on that category which is innate
and immutable President Trump he could
do it in just one day and what is there
to lose the next day he goes back to
Donald it would be a glorious glorious
troll and a very important and
instructive reckoning for a nihilist
deconstructive ideology of gender that
that truly does threaten the the
soundness of our republic it threatens
our logic and our thinking
and you got my vote I can't wait till
you the first woman president I have to
get to Tucker as well before we get out
of here Tucker Carlson speaking of
slut-shaming speaking of speaking of
gender politics the chief LA
correspondent for BuzzFeed Kate Arthur
who may soon need to learn to code I'm
not sure just judging by her writing ID
I suspect she's probably one day going
to be better at coding than writing she
said quote on Twitter remember Tucker
Carlson's lecture during family
separation in June about how the left
doesn't care about family values well
I'm not one to kink shame but here he is
with a sex worker go Tucker that's a but
it's this picture of Tucker Carlson with
a sex worker I don't really know her
history I don't know exactly what kind
of sex work she does my guess she's a
sex worker and it's a picture of her
kind of kissing his cheek and Tucker
turning away and laughing and this was
taken not at some brothel or something
this was taken at the funeral of Dennis
HOF who was a Republican candidate
friend of Tucker Carlson and he he's
also this Nevada kind of pimp figure so
he knew a lot of ladies of the night and
this the woman pictured there it
immediately went after the BuzzFeed
writer she said how dare you we were at
a funeral for our friend and Tucker was
a very nice guy I offered to buy him a
drink he ordered a club soda it's
perfectly well behaved guy what this
shows is that the left is not Pro
prostitute not pro sex worker not it's
not throw anything it's anti
conservative it's anti tradition it's
anti Big Daddy that's what it is big the
religion culture and politics of them of
the civilization that we have of our
tradition that's what it opposes it's Oh
dad I'm so angry at you just wants to
break things down how all that rude to
do this to this this woman the sex
worker it's also pharisaical you know I
was reminded when I saw that tweet this
woman says look this guy talks about
family values and areas with a
prostitute like you know the Pharisees
said the exact same thing about Jesus so
look this guy is giving sermons
about family values and he's hanging out
with prostitutes and tax collectors
right yes right there is a moral
standard and also there is kindness and
mercy because we're all fallen uh-huh
right maybe you've learned you haven't
learned anything
you're just accusing people and
condemning people but you could learn
something if you listen to your own
words I really I guess the whole theme
of the last couple weeks is the left
exposing itself which is an image I
don't really want to think about too
much I think of Hillary no nobody wants
but but it is ideologically exposing
itself and now the big story that's
coming up I think we have a little bit
of time is Michael Cohen switching gears
slightly although I guess this is still
in the theme of exposure Michael Cohen
the president's former personal lawyer
says that he's going to expose Donald
Trump for racism and crimes and lies
while in office this was actually I
think this was the Time magazine
headline moon New York Times Cohen
expected to accuse Trump of Lies
cheating and racism okay what is this
talking about he's going to testify he's
going down to Capitol Hill and he's
going to say the president Trump ordered
him to pay stormy Daniels money to keep
quiet during the 2016 election there's
really a tough argument that this even
constitutes a crime I don't really think
it does constitute a crime there's not a
lot of precedent that would show that
President Trump could be held to account
for paying off stormy Daniels what one
of the good arguments is that Trump has
paid off women all his life this is
business as usual this has nothing to do
is simply with the campaign but it also
raises a question about Cohen because
there were two lines of argument here
one is the Cohen is a dirty rat a
disloyal scum of the earth and he's the
lowest of the low the other is that he's
a liar and that his words and testimony
can't be trusted and been made this
point today on Twitter he said look stop
if you're calling Cohen a liar stop
calling him a rat if he's a rat he's
honest and if he's a liar he's not a rat
think that's quite right rats can be
liars rats usually are liars but it
don't lie about everything nobody lies
about everything
very few people could do that a rat is
someone who's disloyal who's snitches
who is a turncoat who betrays his people
the Dante puts those who betray their
benefactors in the lowest circle of Hell
Casius brutus and judas iscariot rightly
so disloyalty betrayal that is that is
really the lowest of the low it is
unsurprising them that those people also
often tell lies some what are the lies I
don't know clearly Michael Cohen is both
of these things they're not mutually
exclusive
we know that Bob Muller the special
counsel has put the squeeze on Michael
Cohen not just for things he did when he
was working for Trump but for other
transactions other things that he's
worked on throughout his career he says
I got you in this crime I got you in
this crime I got you on this crime
you're never gonna see your wife again
you're never gonna see your kids again
you're never gonna see nobody you're
dead your life is over unless you accuse
Donald Trump of a lot of things I'm what
maybe they're real maybe they're not
real maybe you call him a racist I don't
think racism is a crime yet in this
country but call him a racist that'll be
good that'll help butter up the jury
yeah oh good good he's putting the
squeeze on Cohen Cohen's a rat he's
clearly a rat he's willing to betray his
benefactors and his people and he has
all of the incentives in the world to
lie we know that he's lied he was
convicted of lying he can be both things
at the same time and it's really I felt
during the 2016 campaign conservatives
didn't give Donald Trump enough credit
from loyalty Trump does have a real
loyalty now when people turn on him he
turns on them pretty fast but otherwise
he's had a real loyalty with his people
he keeps people around the Trump
Organization for a fair amount of time
he keeps things close he if he feels
that you've turned on him obviously he
can be as vicious as anybody else but
loyalty is a very important value
without loyalty things break down
without loyalty we're just a bunch of
atoms floating in space we do have bonds
that bind us together to our friends to
our family to our Co partisans to our
countrymen to our people in our
community that loyalty is very important
the truth is very important too we
should put the truth above all things
Michael Cohen has rejected both of them
we shouldn't simply judge the man for
his lies we shouldn't simply judge the
man for his disloyalty the two go
together and it really paints the
picture of a guy who's pretty cheap was
pretty low who's pretty dirty and who
probably shouldn't be taken very
seriously
we'll say Democrats are gonna try to
take him seriously but they've got
nothing they've got the Senate
Intelligence Committee admitted they've
got nothing Bob Muller's so far come up
with nothing
on Trump colluding with Russia the best
they're gonna try to get is paying off
some porn star and Michael Cohen's gonna
try to help them do it
pathetic I'm sure we'll be covering it
though because the media are gonna want
to focus on that rather than focus on
the Kim jong-un summit in in Vietnam
will cover both we'll see which one is
more important to our country which one
is going to be more important to
Americans especially as they look to
2020 that's our show come back tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolan show I'll see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19